we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
this is a really funny voicemail um see
if you can pick up on what's funny about
it take a listen
hey dave i was just wondering do you
want to get
trump out of there what happened to the
21st amendment
right not for office
yeah this is so funny so the 25th
amendment provides a mechanism for
removing donald trump
or any president for being unfit
hilariously the caller mentions the 21st
amendment
which ended prohibition which was put in
place by the 18th amendment
so i know i'm sort of kidding around i
know the caller means the 25th amendment
but i actually started thinking
is there any way we could use the 21st
amendment to justify removing donald
trump i can't think offhand of how we
would do it
but a funny idea but no it is the 25th
amendment that could be used
it will not be used donald trump's
cabinet has no interest in removing him
no matter how
clearly unfit for office he is we will
have a great bonus show for you today we
will talk about whether
it is fair to blame college parties
for the spread of coronavirus or not we
will also
talk about second amendment sanctuary
cities you may or may not have heard of
that
and we will also talk about an
interesting shift within the american
military
the american military now members of the
military
expected to vote for joe biden over
donald trump
that is not the way things usually go in
history with the military vote so all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpakman.com